Oh
I fell in love with the ocean when I was
just a little girl growing up along the
shores well not the shores exactly i was
in new jersey home was on the western
side of New Jersey the ocean is on the
eastern side of New Jersey it was about
a 40 mile trip to go back and forth but
summer vacations for the family brought
me to the shore to meet the Atlantic
Ocean when I was about three years old
then I got knocked over by a wave the
ocean caught my attention what it's
called my attention for well ever since
life life in the sea there's big craggy
horseshoe crabs that would come up on
the beach the seaweed that had that very
distinctive aroma just the starfish the
whole sweep of things you don't see
anywhere on the land home otherwise for
me was on a small farm in New Jersey
both of my parents lived on small farms
as is youngsters southern New Jersey
great farming country so I had the joy
of getting to play in the woods to
explore on my own things that are more
difficult for children to do today but
when I was 12 the family moved to
Florida then my backyard was the Gulf of
Mexico so instead of exploring whatever
kids do if they live in a city the parks
or the streets or whatever i got to
explore the ocean i had a face plate
little face mask was a special gift
because that enables you to see in the
water without your eyes burning dolphins
are lucky and so are whales because they
can easily transition from being
underwater to above but when we go in
the water freshwater or saltwater
everything looks blurry but you put a
face plate on suddenly you can see
everything with clarity and comfort so
that was my first best piece of
equipment for exploring the ocean was
quite a while before I learned about
flippers fins that you could enhance
your speed through the water but that
was some time later I first had a chance
to try breathing underwater when my
older brother borrowed a copper diving
helmet in in cohorts with fight with our
next-door neighbor whose father was a
sponge diver I was the kid sister who
tagged along we went to the Weeki Wachee
river and we took turns no instructions
we just did it had a compressor this
helmet was put on everybody shoulders in
turn and over the side into the river it
was it was exhilarating I thought that
what we're there to do is go look at the
fish underwater and I was amazed because
the fish started gathering around
looking at us for me that was a big
breakthrough the fish are curious they
are which is why I suppose they go for
hooks because agree maybe but also
because they're curious